هكذا كان الفرات وهكذا اصبح في احدث صور
له ساحه للجري وميدان للتهكم عما وصل اليه
الحال في بلد تتلاطمه امواج التناحرات
السياسيه والاقتصاديه بعدما كان احد اغنى
بلدان الشرق الاوسط بالانهر
الصور القادمه من مدينه الناصريه مركز
محافظه ميسان جنوبيه العراق لانخفاض منسوب
المياه حركت السلطات على اعلى المستويات
لمعالجه قضيه المياه حيث عقدت الرئاسه
العراقيه اجتماعا موسعا كرس حول ملف
المياه في البلد
ازمه المياه المتكرره تعد ملفا شائكا
بالنسبه للعراق اذ تتهم بغداد مرارا
جارتيها تركيا وايران بالتسبب في خفض
كميات المياه الواصله الى اراضيها
وسياستهما في بناء السدود على الانهر قبل
دخولها الاراضي العراقيه وزاره الموارد
المائيه العراقيه قالت في بيان لها ان
الانخفاض الحاصل بالحصص المائيه في بعض
المحافظات الجنوبيه عائد الى قله
الايرادات المائيه الوارده الى سد الموصل
على دجله وسد حديثه على الفرات من الجاره
تركيا
يمتلك العراق اكثر من اربعين نهرا على
امتداد اراضيه بعضها تعرض لجفاف كلي
والبعض منها يعاني من جفاف موسمي بسبب
سياسات الجارتين تركيا وايران المائيه وهو
ما يعرض العراق لازمه مياه سنويا بحسب
وزاره الموارد المائيه فان اسبابا انخفاض
مناسيب الانهر يعود الى وصول 30% فقط من
حصه العراق المائيه بينما سبعون بالمئه
تضيع لدى جارتيه ولان الحكومات السابقه لم
تبرم اتفاقيات تلزم تركيا وايران بتامين
حصص العراق المائيه اضافه الى استنفاذ
الوزارتين السابقتين الخزينه المائي بخطه
غير مدروسه
وفقا للامم المتحده فان البلد المكنى
ببلاد الرافدين على مر العصور اصبح من
الدول الخمس الاكثر عرضه للاثار السلبيه
للتغير المناخي في العالم مع تراجع
الامطار وا رتفاع درجات الحراره وازدياد
التصحر